not trying to be misogynistic but I'm
telling you like having cats and rapping
is not where you're going to find your
higher purpose and it's not going to
give you the satisfaction of life that
you could find if you submitted to a man
and it's submitting doesn't have to be
suppressing it's not misogynistic to
submit to your husband that's a woman's
happiest state is submitting to a man
that she loves a woman he's 100 right
you know you know what I believe if if
more women would take that role there'd
be less women on antidepressants but
there are a lot of women here who are
willing to take that role so what is
your point there are a lot of women who
share this mentality you're not
different than them no I am I've made
that clear I'm not gonna lie you're not
like other women no I'm not I don't want
what other women or traditional women or
women that are that what every woman
wants I have a different dream I have a
different purpose
oh
[Music]